getting the Academy Award was one of the
most surreal things in my entire life I
thought how how can I be here how can I
be here at this amazing ceremony with
all these people and to be up for an
award you know that was reward enough
and then when they called our name it
was Sean connory and we were first so I
was super nervous but at least we got it
out of the way which was good so I can
enjoy the rest of the show and the
winner
is R Dennis Muran William George Harley
J and keny Smith for Inner Space it was
so surreal and I was so worried because
you think about you're going to get up
there and talk and everybody's going to
see you everybody you know and everybody
you ever will know so I was so worried
but as soon as the uh names were read I
just went into this like weird space
where I just knew what I needed to do
walked up the stairs and they've got
this little timer that goes to tell you
how much time you have left and I saw we
were a little ahead of schedule so I
slowed down a little also thanks to Ned
Gorman Ed hir in the Stage Department
and then afterwards I went backstage and
kind of went
crazy and the first thing I did
afterwards was I I left the ceremony and
went out into the lobby and called my
family my family was very proud it was
it was an achievement for me but I was
so young I didn't want it to be kind of
like okay your career is at an end I saw
it as okay this is a great point in your
career where you've done this it's time
to move on and it allowed me to move
into another department and led me to
where I am today